hey guys my name is Jess it is the
twentieth of September today and here's
all the latest in video game stuff in
today's episode of games buddies Meyers
Chuck the collection came out last week
and as with a number of pc games in
recent months its had a little bit of
trouble hitting the ground running users
have reported issues ranging from game
crashes to frustration with a lack of
mouth acceleration options hopefully
publisher 2k has acknowledged the issues
and has posted a list of the problems
they plan to address these include
general Mouse fixes an additional
speaker mode improved field of view
slider options support for 21 x 9
display ratios and general stability
improvements you're also encouraged to
report any bugs you encounter on the
official 2k support website next up the
pokemon company have made a number of
announcements about Pokemon Sun and Lee
the pokemon company revealed a bunch of
new Pokemon including / Simeon who has
an ability called ability receiver which
allows it to inherit an ability of an
ally who faints in battle also joining
the fray is the normal psychic-type
arango and the midnight form of the
Pokemon Rock wrath called like and rock
get it like in them because of the full
moon yeah you get it new Pokemon
specific said moves were revealed for
Pikachu and EV and the pokemon company
confirmed the character customization
will be included in Sun and Moon along
with the Pokemon refresh feature that
lets you care for and feed your Pokemon
it was also revealed that the Pokemon
bank feature won't be available at
launch in November and will instead
arrive in January of 2017 this feature
allows players to move Pokemon
wirelessly from previous games in the
series for all the nitty-gritty details
on Pokemon Sun and Moon check out a
story on site the pokemon company
weren't done dropping knowledge there
though as they've also suggested what we
might be getting with nintendo's and x
pokemon company CEO tsunekazu ishihara
told the Wall Street Journal the annex
is trying to change the concept of what
it means to be a home console device or
a handheld device we will make games for
the NX this seems to lend credence to
the rumor that the NX will be a console
mobile hybrid although the CEO would not
confirm
the Pokemon companies and X Games would
be available when the console launches
in March of next year recently nintendo
of america president reggie fils-aime a
spoke about the NX in comparison to the
struggling with you saying one of the
things we have to do better when we
launch the NX we have to do a better job
of communicating the positioning for the
product we have to do a better job of
helping people to understand its
uniqueness and what that means for the
game playing experience head to game
swap the stories on gears for Skylanders
and our review of forza horizon 3 and
i'll be back with more nice work